mais guizhou awashish a retrouvé la
communauté innu de machouillettes si
cher à ses yeux beaucoup plus vite que
prévu pandémie oblige
une situation dont le jeune homme de 19
ans a choisi de tirer avantage
je peux être aidée d'un jour seulement
de bouger en acteur ou de me reposer on
peut dire sinon j'ai développé une
passion pour la course la course à pied
je fais des activités avec justement ma
soeur comme détruire en canot sur le lac
c'est toutefois à contrecoeur qu'il a
terminé sa session en sciences de la
nature au cégep de baie-comeau à
distance et abandonner sa première
saison officielle dans la ligue de
hockey junior majeur du québec
ça a été une petite épreuve un peu
émotive là j'étais un peu déçu en fait
très déçu surtout si je pensais au rgo
pluvieux qui eux
vous voyez leur carrière terminée comme
si nos juniors l'attaquant du drakkar de
baie comeau s'est dit tout de même
satisfait des parties qu'il a jouées
même si leur et amy se faire valoir en
séries éliminatoires ni guiziou awashish
reste toutefois serein il n'en est pas à
ses premières embûches pour devenir
l'athlète et l'étudiant accompli qu'il
est il a fait plusieurs sacrifices dont
celui de quitter le nid familial à l'âge
de 15 ans ses efforts et son implication
dans sa communauté lui ont d'ailleurs
valu le premier trophée à l'écrit dans
avril
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir une très bonne
famille qui pourrait me soutenir dans
toutes les épreuves ce soit des échecs
j'ai toujours eu ma table naldo pour me
remonter le moral ou me féliciter c'est
un jeune homme qui est très persévérant
qui sait
il ya toujours été comme seul qui est à
faire des sacrifices et des sacrifices
tient de fait énormément deux
autochtones ont été tués par la police
ce mois ci du guizhou awashish n'a pas
souvent été victime de racisme
même s'il en a été témoin la mort
récente de deux autochtones aux mains de
la police les interpellent tous tes
croyances populaires tout ce qui est
préjugés en fait ça pour beaucoup de
l'éducation l'éducation non seulement à
l'école mais aussi la transmission de
parents enfin beaucoup beaucoup de prêts
conception sont fait pisser
préconceptions le sont rares même
positive long 11 entend donc s'il ya
beaucoup de travail à faire par rapport
à ce que c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
que chaouchi qui guide ou awashish
aimerait bien jouer dans une ligue
professionnelle doit à quai en amérique
du nord ou en europe
mais avant il souhaite développer son
potentiel tout en allant à l'université
ici milsa paradis radio-canada
mâchouille as